you've had a lot of injuries can you
just tell us some of the injuries you've
had um I've had like four knee surgeries
I've just got my shoulder my collarbone
my foot I mean all kinds of things but
really what's the worst one you've had I
you know what the thing that bothers me
most is like paper cuts you know the
feeling that they give like in your scan
like yes like I have goose bumps right
now right like I'm shaking it's the idea
of it so you've had like your arm ripped
off and sewn back on but you fear a
paper cut more than anything else I've
had someone dislocate my elbow I popped
it back in myself and still wone them
right I would rather have that so what
if they come at you with an envelope
[Applause]
you